Liz Cheney is warning that Donald Trump
if he is reelected might refuse to leave
office believe that Donald Trump were
elected next year that he would try to
stay in office Beyond a second term that
he would never leave office there's no
question you think he would try to stay
in power forever absolutely I mean he's
already done it once and in fact if you
look at what he did in the runup to
January 6th in terms of his pressure on
the vice president not to count
legitimate electoral votes his pressure
on the Department of Justice on State
officials and then refusing to send help
when the capital was under attack um
he's already attempted to seize power
and he was stopped um thankfully and and
for the good of the nation and the
Republic uh but but he said he will do
it again he's expressed No Remorse for
what he did we know that Donald Trump
will not refuse to give up power and the
reason we know that is he already did it